welcome back everybody the new year just
would not be the same without making
resolutions so we'll go right around the
table degan you're up uh what is your
resolution stop eating fox snacks
oh
good one so i've been at work every
single day during most of us were during
covid and i started eating snacks that i
normally wouldn't doritos cool ranch
doritos chex mix gummy welch's gummy
treats and i've gained a lot of weight
stop biting my fingernails which i
started during kova 2 which i won't show
you what they look like but it's really
really bad and then i want to see my dad
more often in my family here's my daddy
there's daddy and charlie that's nice my
dad's he's a cool dude good good nascar
guy i i speaking of family that's one of
my resolutions to see my grandchildren
my lovely grandchildren
to watch them grow
there's a bunch of shots we've seen
those already they though they're
wonderful wonderful five of them and
they're they're grown great i want to
get a new dog
my dog is uh my two dogs that i have now
are 12 years old i want them to have a
buddy and i want to see the buddy before
i follow the two old dogs
[Laughter]
i want to stay cute into my 80s thank
you oh you're well on your way
and i'm going to resist getting a
haircut until someone like shaves off
half of it when i'm asleep i love it wow
you look good dana what's your
resolution uh okay so i two years ago i
started a resolution where i would do
something to help my posture every day
stayed with that and so now i'm going to
twice a day because it's such a hard
thing what do you do yeah all sorts of
things like it's like saying uh
exercises videos little posture things
doesn't have to take that long sometimes
it's only like a three minute thing so
while we're on the conference call in
the morning you don't know i'm doing my
posture exercises why would you do the
confidence
is that your best basic fitness
is that your basic fitness i do a little
pilates and the peloton of course okay
the other one is keep i'm going to
actually do this
in writing this year i'm going to keep a
daily gratitude journal because i think
that it is scientifically proven
every time you express gratitude it's
like a little shot of serotonin like you
are running so like why wouldn't you do
that so i'm gonna do that and then i'm
going to try every time i want to buy a
book to get it from a local bookstore
before i try to get it online
excellent and so the the gratitude is i
i am thankful for yeah and then you
write something down every day that's
very nice how about you so my number one
one is to be nicer to jessica tarloff
who are you mean to her people say i am
lots of people and so it's something i'm
gonna and i only give you've been
meeting her when she's pregnant
yes geraldo she's pregnant before she
was pregnant i think i just have to be a
little more patient and and i only do it
because i love her i think she's great
number two is my working on my posture
and i only slouch because i sit next to
short people you guys are short
you're short so i just have to think
about
being a wreck
uh and then also waking up earlier
because sometimes you know when the five
is on at five you can get up i can help
you with that do you want me to call you
when i get up eight o'clock i wanna wait
what time do you get up wait will you
get 4 45.
i have a baby dagon
i've been getting up at 2 30 in the
morning for 12 years i mean i have not
always gotten up at eight i went through
a long time where i was getting up and
you can make megan cry
i want to get up at six six o'clock
maybe 6 15.
i'm gonna go to the gym and work on my
posture jesse take it from me that ain't
gonna happen no you are not getting up
here get advice oh now i'm definitely
getting about my resolution is to have a
resolution free zone i'm a freak about
you guys going to hate me but i don't do
resolutions yeah me neither i think it's
better to give back than to give up i
think giving up is all about lent what
about your adding i'm adding no but well
what i was thinking was your next great
book is going to be 365 days of
gratitude okay i could do that but i
could also do 365 days of posture and
you can promote it 365 days of the year
there's no way you only promoted that
book 32 times yeah they're making a lot
of mistakes on the show promoting you
like 10 times per show
do we count that
first show
but bill that's interesting that are you
superstitious about no i just i don't
think anything really sticks i mean you
want to give up weight or your alcohol
for give up weight you want to lose
weight or give up alcohol for the month
of january a lot of people do that
that's fine i'm just saying that jesse
is not getting up earlier in his life
i mean i may hit snooze once or twice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else